I want you back I'm not very good at
this I've never wanted to try again
that's dinner with me okay fine I will
have dinner with you because I'm hungry
but we are only talking and that is it
gotta be quicker than that grace are you
happy I've never been happier take him
off
[Music]
you got me
[Music]
your boyfriend has a reputation do you
want to be kept or have respect
do you think you're the first woman who
tried to save him
[Music]
he's changing it's not what he wants
anymore but it's what he needs
[Music]
[Music]
you're just gonna stand there gawking
yes
[Music]
if something were to happen to you I
could never forgive myself
[Music]
in trade
[Music]
this time no rules no punishments and no
more secrets
[Music]
if something were to happen to you I
could never forgive myself if you got
hit
[Music]
[Music]
I want you back I had no idea what this
was gonna become I don't see how this
can work you're just gonna stand there
gawking yes anyone Anastasia this time
no rules no punishments no more secrets
baby you go
you do you think you're the first woman
who's tried to save him
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you treat mr. grey will see you now
I'm used to getting my own way
must be really boring it's the sexy film
it's the ebb and flow of passion and
control it's just beyond this door what
is there Clara thank you Xbox system
it's not see people who are trying to
find a link and a connection and trying
to overcome with this issue of how he
leads his life you seem nervous I find
you intimidating if Anastasia
unlocks this whole site and he breaks so
many of his own rules and this is about
you so different she has an effect of
him that no one else has had it feels
like a fairy tale although this is a
very adult version
they've have an undeniable connection
they've each never loved someone as much
as they love each other
you